[Musica]
ma perché non mi aspettavo un mai va
bene bello a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti
a questo video ne sono faringei comunque
sia un giusto gioco e la partenza mi ha
spiazzato e passata una gallina quindi
sarà un gioco di qualità negativa ho
speso anche 8 euro e 99
vediamo subito se gli ho buttati allora
è pressochè i solo perché sono da solo a
posto cambiarmi il colore va bene io non
ho ragazzi credo sia un gioco dove devi
arrivare a un certo punto della mappa
usando le braccia però non mi spieghi
come funziona quindi non lo so a skip to
tò riall perfetto o che utilizza questo
promuovere le tue braccia e figo acero
ok usa i trigger per aggravarle e fin
qua ci sono ho capito così ad usare deve
devo semplicemente arrivare alla fine
del livello aggrappandomi e tipo di rock
swing di è più vi voglio parlare sono
fatti un po meglio quanto pare va bene
la cosa bella è che il suo gioco si può
fare in coop
quindi se è bello mi terrò un sacco gli
amici per giocarci e vedere se riusciamo
ad andare avanti però per ora devo
cavarmela da solo allora quanti usare la
tua forza brutta anche se le tue braccia
sono spese come le mie realtà e quindi è
che tu abbia chissà che forza bruta però
prova a lanciarti bellissimo ci si può
anche lanciare ragazzi gioco dell'anno
credo che se invitasse i miei amici sta
roba ci divertiremo tutti tantissimo e
io riesco ad arrivare al traguardo
no madonna mi sono salvato tantissimo se
non è questo gioco dell'anno lo so io
vuole potrebbe essere ragazzi fantastico
come ho fatto a non conosce il suo gioco
prima come ci arrivo lì pro a battere il
record prova batte il record del mondo
di stampa allora mi lancio da qua se
riesco ne scova ok se ti riesce a
lanciati talmente forte da beccare il
coso
ma se che forse mi come andare di sopra
ma ci provo ci provo ci provo
ci ho provato
era difficile non potevo pretendere
quindi l'obiettivo è arrivare alla fine
prima degli altri immagino con in coop
devo assolutamente farlo online sembra
una scalata della mia vita qui ecco
quella è che il più quelle che ho
scalato adesso erano le superiori per
intenderci
ecco questo è youtube tram che ti illude
però poi alla fine tv la testata è una
metafora della vita questo gioco
bellissimo
ok ora ti aggrappi e dei bilanci non è
di phil va bene lo stesso va ben
bravissimo ragazzi sono pronto per
giocare online
c'è veramente le sorti di temi che
c'erano ditemi che c'è uno online perché
devo assolutamente farlo cooperativa non
è online porco demonio porco o adesso
riconosco un po la la roba di super meat
boy le spine mi mancavano quel demonio
benissimo no sono io non l'ho toccata
per milano comunque veramente fatto da
dio c'è veramente è un gioco bellissimo
peccato non l'abbiano fatto online sono
dei pazzi sarebbe stato fighissimo
va bene bahamas questa vi piacerà
ragazzi
voglio tra yard aree sud sui livelli
ragazzi questo voglio farlo lanciandomi
dalla parte opposta non so quanto ci
riuscirò no sto scherzando facciamolo
normalmente forse è meglio allora allora
allora facciamo le cose fatte bene
centra il buco nella vita è difficile ma
provaci
c'è un piccione il piccione l'hanno
ripreso da come si chiama come schiava
ragazzi quel gioco tipo cupi che che
scavi sulla montagna alle show dificioni
maledizione che ti dà fastidio è un
riferimento a quello che ho giocato gip
circolo giocato un miliardo di volte
bellissimo anche se non o mio dio così
mia cagato addosso fantastico
non ho ben capito se co demonio non
avrei capito se sti uccelli ti da
fastidio cosa senti di aggrapparti
perché a quanto pare si levano quindi
non sono un ostacolo nell'altro lo erano
i ragazzi veramente ho dovuto ripassare
la bibbia mentre giocava con la roba lì
ho finalmente nella sfida vera qua ci
sarà da cristo nare che la metà bassa
ragazzi ve lo dico già il primo è
abbastanza easy semmai devo fare così
per tutti di vento stupido non che sia
mai stato intelligente però perché la
mia vita fa schifo si è creata una roba
che non c'era prima di me diventa un
rock swing sul serio è sparita ma perché
sono dei bonus momentanei ma che figata
raga mai fatto benissimo sto gioco ma
voi giocate non posso chiamare un amico
che viene a casa mia a giocarsi poi
polmoni ma allora ragazzi sono i
galletti difficilissimo non sto
scherzando ma perché voce schifo non sto
scherzando suo livello un casino perché
hanno messo le cose
distanziate il giusto per farti per
segnare dai perfetto perfetto c'è un
piccione di non darmi fastidio avere
l'avere avvio dio ha fatto le cose devo
teoricamente lanciarmi ho fatto roba ho
fatto roba e va bene va bene per chi se
ne frega molto discutibile questo ma va
bene ragazzi è bellissimo non finirò mai
di dirlo mi sembra un misto tra giro
e getting operi per deciso dopo dirla
tutta prova bene ho fatto rope non so
neanche come tra altrove il bello che la
videocamera si sposta lentamente non
mica garante ecco quello secondo me da
fastidio quello secondo me se ti
colpisce un problema
[Musica]
e invece no il mercato solo in testa c'è
sulla mano mancato sulla mano ma fa
niente pensa no madonna non li avevo
visti no pensavo fosse un elemento di
distrazione quella fare giuro
a quanto pare non lo era meno male io
ipocondriaco semi percassi una cacca di
piccione nella vita reale probabilmente
mi staccare il braccio procura un altro
discorso
ragazzi sto a livelli veramente lungo se
cado muoiono completa censis solo non
restare sparano dall'inizio quindi
potrei incazzarmi sul serio non morire
zio per cortesia
no no ti prego ti prego di micron e
verdini che non mi fa ripartire da lì
dio vi ringrazio come possibile ma non
ci parlo mai di segnare anche se puoi
meno male che c'era un secco no ragazzi
non sarei non ce l'avrei mai fatta
non devi segnale meli checkpoint e devi
andare a sentimento come quando metti il
parmigiano sulla pasta non so quale mano
sta tenendo che meno male che regola
giusta ma vede ciò che hai fatto
tantissimo fatto benissimo è però il
problema è che quando passano 18 liano
quanto dura sto livello un anno va bene
per noi va benissimo ma torna raga
veramente atroce gioco della vita
poi tanto quando arrivi alla fine se
schiacci questo tasto fa questa cosa che
non ho ben capito però va bene no al
buio no no ragazzi al buio non sono
capace capiamoci al buio non capiscono
anche dove il traguardo almeno un aiuto
ditemi dove devo andare non lo so devo
immagino a scalare qua mi sono affidato
ho fatto bene ma ho mancato il buco
buono ragazzi al buio potrebbe essere un
problema sta piano piano di sopra
va bene va bene ragazzi ottimo perfetto
proprio lui questa era abbastanza easy
si alternano rom e impossibili a cagare
immigrati la testa per cortesia
grazie non so se ha funzionato non le
volevo fare ma spero di sì devo
inventarmi delle cagate perché sennò non
ha senso che abbia 5 milioni e mezzo di
iscritti deve avere un senso quello che
faccio però vai piano ti prego
va bene granoche mori tantissimo ok
dov'è il traguardo non lo vedo non è
vero
la donna che non guarda se non prendo
chiacchierato sta roba guarda non prendo
più nessuno ci erano parole non ho
parole non ci credo mai nella vita
come ho fatto essere così stupido è
difficilissimo
mori secondo me proprio ci va bene
ottimo no che culo ma tornare grande ha
pure qua veramente ma graziato gesù
sembra anche un po a yen brad che quello
dove controlli il pezzo di pane però qua
non c'è il grip che dopo un po hd grazie
a dio sarebbe veramente infattibile
madonna mezz'ora di scalata fate finire
questo supplizio di supplico dov'è il
finale ma non c'è il finale devo ma pure
ma come quanto può quanto conto quanto
lungo da ragazzi per questo penso sia a
livello 9 e vero sono partito più avanti
di prima baba bene ragazzi dove stia
manda basta non ce la faccio più
orribile qua devo fare un salto
chilometrico immagino c'era una roba di
mezzo né o dio mio
non ci ragazzi meno guarda cui se il
ponte sono stati buonissimi il ceco i
circuiti non mi posso lamentare
veramente perché sono stati super però
mamma mia ragazzi c'è poco una roba
previsto se pensa se fosse come keting o
veri senza check point
la morte è fatta videogioco basta tre
minuti e 35 solo per fare questo livello
farò un altro episodio ma vorrei fare
l'in cooperativa quindi invito ai miei
amici bellissimo geniale verrà ragazzi
viene se avete schiacciate il tasto
iscriviti end la campanella abusivamente
aggiornati sui nuovi video che escono e
noi come sempre ci vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]